our chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook joins us now John good morning
you you heard the vice president say he
was recently tested he tested negative
so he doesn't need to wear a mask should
he wear a mask you know the problem
Anthony is that the president said that
he's tested regularly and that he does
not have corona virus the problem is you
can test negative for corona virus but
still be infected and here's how first
of all we know that the test is not
perfect so you can have what's called a
false negative where you do the swab in
the nose of the throat and it says that
you don't have it but actually you do
have it the second way is trickier and
that's the issue of incubation so
somebody can be infected but remember
that incubation period is 2 to 14 days
and during that period a test would be
negative because it hasn't blossomed yet
in the back of the throat and the nose
so the test is gonna be negative at any
time then after the test was negative
it could then come out a kit blossom and
of course the problem is you can be
spreading the virus a symptomatically
you don't have to have any symptoms at
all now we don't know exactly what the
timing is when his last test was we
asked but we were not told I have to say
that I have patients who have had
similar questions they've said to me I
tested negative do I still need to him
wear a mask and I've said yes and
finally with that there's the issue of
modeling so you have the Mayo Clinic
rules which say patients and visitors
should be wearing these masks
everybody's wearing the masks except for
vice-presidents so what message does
that send right John
some states have started to reopen some
will open this week what message would
you have to people in those states I
would say don't prematurely celebrate I
think you have to go slowly it reminds
me of traveling in a car down a long and
winding road right and suddenly you
decide you're gonna step on the
accelerator and go fast if you're gonna
do that you better have your eyes open
and believe me we are on a long and
winding road and having our eyes open
here means having a lot of testing
enough testing so that we know what's
going on in a certain area and we're
talking about both types of tests
Anthony we're talking about the test to
see do you have the infection and also
the test to see whether you had it so
you have to go slowly you have to go
careful
yeah I was in Central Park here in New
York yesterday a lot more people out
weather warming up a lot of cabin fever
people sensing things have turned the
ink the urge is to go out now John I
completely understand and empathize with
that I mean you know it's been months
now and people are starting to get itchy
you know they want to go out they want
to hug people they want to get back to
normal and I think it's a natural
instinct I know I know it's hard to
continue to do the same thing you know
the physical distancing and all the
things that we've been doing but I think
it's so important the last thing we want
to do is to let our foot off of the gas
pedal in terms of doing all of these
efforts and that have this pandemic just
come roaring right back so we've got to
go slow but of course we all empathize
with our desire we all have spring fever
we want to get out and around alright
dr. Jon LaPook thank you John